et justement elle a même si c'est une
branche histoire d'amour est ici sur ce
plateau du bien beau tour normal a
concocté un magnéto juste pour vous
regardez c'est à mourir de rire
petit intermède divertissement tours de
magie c'est par là voulez vous soufflez
je vais bien souple et disparitions et
passager mal
des trucs cachés dans le sud mais là je
te monde
attention à la disparue temps qui met
les boules je fais vous demandez de
choisir une carte en entendre parler
montrons pas ce que ça peut être
dangereux s'est magnifié voilà c'est
quand même assez bon c'est quand même le
plus beau de france
allez je vais détendre l'ambiance ça
avec un petit tour de magie ça me coûte
2 secondes et ça détend toujours
l'ambiance
semoun de couper ya un truc est toujours
étonnant les magiciens ici j'adore ça
passe quoi qu'est ce cas là dedans bon
là je vais demander à cyril hanouna de
retourner cette carte là bas c'est
dingue 6 et 7 6 7
si c'est ça la rondeur du blanc mais si
c'est ça
si c'est celle là moi je trouve
[Applaudissements]